♪ ♪
>> Trace: HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SECRETARY ALEX AZAR IN
JACKSONVILLE, FLORIDA, TO GET A
FIRSTHAND LOOK AT THE LOCAL
RESPONSE TO COVID-19.
HE MET WITH HEALTH CARE LEADERS
AND TOURED A TESTING SITE.
HE JOINS US LIVE FROM FLORIDA.
SECRETARY AZAR, I KNOW YOU ARE
BUSY, I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
I’M CURIOUS WHY A TESTING SITE
IN FLORIDA.
AS THE MESSAGE HERE TESTING IS
OF THE UTMOST IMPORTANCE TO GET
A HANDLE ON THE CORONAVIRUS?
>> WELL, ABSOLUTELY.
TESTING IS IMPORTANT BUT THANKS
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP’S RESPONSE
AND GOVERNOR DeSANTIS
LEADERSHIP WE HAVE THE
PRECONDITIONS TO GET REOPENED
AND GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AND
GET OUT LIVING OUR LIVES AGAIN.
I WANTED TO COME HERE AND SEE
THIS COMMUNITY BASED TESTING
SITE AT THE JACKSONVILLE JAGUAR
STADIUM BEING LED BY THE
TREMENDOUS NATIONAL GUARD AND
THE JACKSONVILLE FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
ANOTHER 27 OF THE SITES ACROSS
THE STATE.
AND GETTING GOOD TESTING LIKE
THAT PART OF THE ONGOING
RESPONSE TO THE CORONAVIRUS.
>> Trace: I WANT TO PUT THIS
ON THE SCREEN IF I CAN.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU CAN SEE
THIS, MR. SECRETARY BUT CONCERN
HOW PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
TESTING.
FOX NEWS POLL, LACK OF TESTING
63% BELIEVE IT IS A PROBLEM.
THE LACK OF CLEAR PLAN FROM THE
GOVERNMENT, 61% ALSO AGREE THAT
IS A PROBLEM.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE TO THOSE
PEOPLE, SIR?
>> WELL, THAT IS NOT BASED IN
THE ACTUAL REALITIES, BUT OUR
JOB IS TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THE TESTING
CAPABILITIES THAT WE HAVE.
WE’VE DONE OVER 12 MILLION TESTS
IN THE COUNTRY WHICH IS
UNPRECEDENTED.
WE WILL DO 12 MILLION MORE IN
THE COMING WEEKS.
WE HAVE THE TESTING CAPACITY TO
GET THE JOB DONE BUT THROUGH
TESTING SITES LIKE THIS, WE ARE
ABLE TO MAKE IT MORE CONVENIENT
FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE ACCESSIBLE
AND SIX PART MULTIFACTOR PLAN
FOR HOW WE DEAL WITH THIS.
THIRD WE CAN CONTAIN OUTBREAKS,
FOURTH WE HAVE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM RESILIENCE WITH CAPACITY
AND SUPPLIES.
FIFTH, WE DEVELOP THERAPEUTICS
TO TREAT PEOPLE AND THEN SIXTH,
VACCINES TO MARKET UNDER THE
PRESIDENT’S OPERATION WARP SPEED
PLAN.
>> Trace: AND WE TALKED A
SHORT WHILE AGO HOW SOME OF
THESE VACCINES ARE VERY
ENCOURAGING.
YOU WROTE AN OP-ED MR. SECRETARY
IN "THE WASHINGTON POST" AND I
WANT TO PUT THAT ON THE SCREEN
AND READ IT TO YOU AND GET THE
TAKE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
"RETURNING TO NORMAL’S AND ABOUT
BALANCING HEALTH VERSUS THE
ECONOMY.
IT IS ABOUT BALANCING HEALTH
VERSUS HEALTH.
THE HEALTH RISK OF COVID-19
BALANCED AGAINST TO HELP SOCIAL
ECONOMIC COST OF KEEPING
MAINSTREAM ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES CLOSED FOR
BUSINESS."
WHICH IS YOUR WAY OF SAYING LOOK
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE HEALTH
BUT WE HAVE TO GET THIS COUNTRY
UP AND RUNNING AGAIN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AS I SAID IN THE OP-ED, IT IS
NOT HEALTH VERSUS THE ECONOMY,
HEALTH VERSUS HEALTH BY BEING
LOCKED IN AND SHUT AWAY, WE DENY
OURSELVES CRITICAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
THE ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
DISLOCATION FROM BEING SHUT DOWN
IS LEADING TO MENTAL ILLNESS AND
SUICIDE RISK.
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF CASES NOT
BEING SCREENED AND DIAGNOSED AND
TREATED.
WE HAVE KIDS WITH GOOD
PEDIATRICS VACCINATION AND
PROCEDURES THAT ARE NOT
HAPPENING AT THE MAYO CLINIC, IT
WAS ANXIOUS TO GET THEM BACK UP
AND RUNNING AGAIN.
SCREENINGS AND SURGERIES GOING.
SO THIS COUNTRY HAS TO GET BACK
TO WORK.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO SCHOOL.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO LIVING
AND THERE ARE SAFE WAYS TO DO
WITH THINGS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
RESPONSE AND THE GOVERNOR’S
LEADERSHIP.
>> Trace: I’M WONDERING
SECRETARY AZAR, WHY FLORIDA?
THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS IN
ORLANDO, JACKSONVILLE BUT ARE
YOU SAYING THIS IS EMBLEMATIC OF
FLORIDA, EMBLEMATIC WHAT THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY SHOULD
FOLLOW IN THE OPENING PROCESS?
FLORIDA WAS HIGHLY CRITICIZED
HOW IT HANDLED THE PANDEMIC AS
WELL AS OPENING TO EARLY.
IS THIS A STATEMENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION OF SOME SORT?
>> NO, IT IS NOT, ALTHOUGH AS
YOU LOOK AT FLORIDA AND HOW THE
GOVERNOR HAS HANDLED THINGS, THE
DATA TEND TO PROVE THAT.
NOT AN OUTLIER IN TERMS OF
DISEASE BURDEN.
I WAS IN NORTH CAROLINA ON THE
WAY HERE.
I WAS ABLE TO BE IN CHARLOTTE
WHERE GOVERNOR COOPER, OF
COURSE, DOING A GREAT JOB AND
TODAY HAS MOVED INTO PHASE TWO
TRAIN OF THE REOPENING PLANS.
SO REALLY COMMIT TO CELEBRATING
THE GOVERNORS AND THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE STRUGGLED AND SUFFERED
THROUGH THIS.
NOW WE ARE SAYING WE NEED TO GET
BACK TO WORK, IN THE SCHOOLS,
THE COMMUNITY BUT WE CAN DO IT
IN A SAFE AND APPROPRIATE WAY.
>> Trace: AND I LASTLY VERY
QUICKLY WANT TO -- I KNOW
THERE’S A LOT OF PUSH ON AND I
ANTIBODY TESTING.
YOU ARE SAYING SOME OF THESE
HAVE NOT BEEN APPROVED.
IS IT SAFE TO SAY THE ANTIBODIES
MIGHT NOT BE FACTUAL BECAUSE OF
THE TESTS THAT WERE NOT
ACCURATE?
>> SO WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THE
TESTS WERE AVAILABLE IN THE
COUNTRY WITHOUT REGULATORY
DELAY.
SO WE LET THEM COME ONTO THE
MARKET AND FORCED THEM ALL TO
COME IN FOR FDA REVIEW WHILE IN
THE MARKET.
WE HAVE APPROVED TEN OF THESE
AND THESE ANTIBODY TEST THROUGH
THE FDA.
AT THAT POINT, WE SAID, YOU KNOW
WHAT, YOU NEED TO PRESENT THE
DATA AND VALIDATED.
FOR THE ONES THAT DID NOT SUBMIT
THE DATA WE HAVE ORDERED OFF OF
THE MARKET.
ACTUALLY BEHIND ME, THEY HAVE
ANTIBODY TESTING.
ONE OF THE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
AND RESPONDERS TO GET IN A BODY
TESTING, DIAGNOSTIC TESTING IN